crapped up and high-waisted jeans with
pink lip and jellies very cute this is
my third episode in my turning 30 series
where Olay has given me a set of
challenges for my body heart mind and
soul in this episode we're gonna be
focusing on my mind growing up I always
thought that I would live in New York
City but I found myself settling down
here in LA and it was a little bit of a
mind shift for a planner like me so this
weekend I'm gonna celebrate this crazy
glitzy glamorous hot dry a beautiful
city and why it's my home when you have
a big day on the town with your friends
I want my skin to stay happy so I'm
trying this new Olay Regenerist whip
goes on really smooth it's not shiny
I'm not oily whoo I really like this if
you're not starting your la day out with
brunch you're doing it wrong
you don't have to wake up early for it
you literally can eat anything and it
comes with mimosas it's so cool because
after brunch we were just wandering
around in the neighborhood and we
happened upon this beautiful outdoor
flower market I have a vision for my
little succulent family
walking a bookstore and just kind of
getting lost just like a very chill
activity where you can kind of turn your
brain off and I don't know if 25 year
old me would have been interested in
that kind of activity so I call that
growth getting out of your car climbing
a mountain and then looking at views is
so great for your mental health one of
the biggest things I love about Los
Angeles is that I'm so close to nature
and honestly that's not something I
thought I would need when I was younger
as much as I never thought that LA was
gonna be my home kind of my home it is
my home la in general is not like New
York because it's not one big city it's
a collection of little cities and little
neighborhoods and there are so many
great bars and nightlife in those little
cities that you just have to know where
to go then I got pretty hungry and I
wanted to find my favorite snack which
are tacos I don't love pizza I'll eat
meat those around in LA the drunk food
is tacos you can eat like 12 tacos and
feel okay you can't eat 12 slices of
pizza and feel okay if you're a person
in protein your 30s and you're looking
at your life and you're like calm and I
really thought things would go
differently I really challenge you to
maybe look at all the things you do love
about your life and where you are
sometimes when I think about New York
City I do get sad like I was always
destined to be there but I'm not there
however this weekend was just an
opportunity for me to revisit my
favorite places in LA and it just kind
of reaffirmed the fact that this is my
home now and I love it here it was
emotional this game is emotion